hi there today we're looking at every
model
learned by gradient descent is
approximately a kernel machine
by pedro domingos this paper on a high
level
establishes a theoretical connection
between
gradient descent learned models such as
deep neural networks
and kernel machines as you might know
them from topics such as support vector
machines
the paper interprets its own finding as
meaning that deep neural networks
essentially store that training data in
their parameters
as a superposition and when when a new
data point comes in
what it does it is it sort of compares
the data point to the stored training
data
and then decides with relation to that
what the output should be which is of
course exactly what a
kernel machine does so
it is a theoretical paper and um
we're we're gonna go over it i'm not an
entire expert on these things
but the main theorem is fairly
easy to grasp and the proof behind it is
also fairly easy
so i thought it'd be a good paper to
look over
further pedro is coming to our machine
learning street talk podcast
in the future and i wanted to get
familiar
with his work so you know if
you like content like this too let me
know um
let me know if you understood it or not
or
if i just made it worse uh yeah
let's dive into the abstract the
abstract is actually a pretty good
summarization of
what the conclusions of the paper are
it says deep learning successes are
often attributed to its ability to
automatically discover
new representations in the data rather
than relying on handcrafted features
like other learning methods and
as you might know this is a success
story of deep learning
before deep learning we had to do a lot
of handcrafting
of features where expert knowledge went
into problems and then
we would simply aggregate the
handcrafted features with
some sort of linear classifier or you
know in some cases a kernel
kernel classifier though the hand
crafting of features would also go
into kernel design deep neural networks
are different because we just feed in
the training data as is
and the deep neural network will
automatically discover
the features that are important
at least that's the prevailing notion of
what's happening this paper challenges
this view
they say we show however that deep
networks learned by the standard
gradient descent algorithm
are in fact mathematically approximately
equivalent to kernel machines
a learning method that simply memorizes
the data
and uses it directly for prediction via
a similarity function
the kernel so that's the the main thesis
of the paper they show that it is
equivalent to kernel machine
if you if you don't know uh anything
about kernels
don't worry there is a good machine
learning street talk
episode uh with alex stenlick where i
get to ask
all the dumb questions about kernels
so you don't have to ask them so if
you're interested in that
check that out as well that's on the
machine learning street talk
podcast they say this greatly enhances
the interpretability
of deep network weights by elucidating
that they are effectively a
superposition of
the training examples okay so
saying again that the the deep neural
networks they essentially store the
training data in their weights and then
use
that to compare new data points too
now the conclusion of this paper is is
interesting i
i don't fully agree like i don't agree
with the
the the framing here that it's sort of
replacing this notion i
think this gives rise to sort of a dual
view of the problem
it is a way that you can also look
at these deep neural networks i don't
think
it kind of changes like it can both be
true
that they do discover good
representations and also are a
superposition of the training
data i think it's simply a different way
of looking at the problem
however i as i said i'm not a super
duper expert
um on this and they allude to the fact
here that
this improved understanding should lead
to better learning algorithms
and of course even though this paper
here is has no
impact for practitioners down the road
this could actually
have some of some impact
so what is a kernel machine a kernel
machine is this thing right here so in
machine learning
we always want to we have some x and
this is our input data and we want to
get some y
now for the purposes of this paper think
of y being just a number so think of
linear regression okay not linear but
just
regression where y as a number x is a
data point
and we want a function f that assigns
each data point a number
and then that number is going into a
loss function
so there is going to be a loss function
that compares that number
to the number that we have in the
training data set our true label
y star okay so we have training data x
i this gives so the neural network gives
an output y
we compare that to the true label in the
loss function
now a kernel machine is
a particular way of how this f here is
built
and usually if you think of this as a
neural network you simply say oh x goes
into layer layer layer layer
and at the end you get y okay a kernel
machine is different
a kernel machine actually builds a a
database
of all the training examples so
what it would do is it takes your
training data set
and it would sort of build a list of all
the training data points
in here i see i'm duper super
oversimplifying this
but it will build a list of all the
training data right here
and now when you want to know about a
new data point say you want to classify
this
x right here what it will do is it'll go
to its database
and it will compare x to each
of those training data points to each
and from each of those training data
points you get a response
of how similar is x to that training
data point
so for for the first training data point
you would get a score of how similar
that is
and that score is computed by this
kernel function
so x1 and kernel of x with
x2 you get kernel of x with x3
so for each data point you want to know
how similar
is the data point that you wonder about
to the data points that you've already
seen if we
look at this in kind of a schematic so
let's say this is our data space
and you have kind of a data point here
and one here
and one here and one here in the
training data set
and you want to know how should i
classify this red data point
right here your kernel will tell you and
it looks easy
if it's on the plane but it's not easy
at all
in high dimensions with complicated data
like images or
or structured data it's not as easy as
simply taking the distance though here
it is so here a good kernel function
would simply be the euclidean distance
to these data points
and this says something like the kernel
function would tell you that
these two data points right here are
very similar to the data point we care
about
well these two data points right here
are not that similar
so when you classify the data point
you consider all the data in your
training data set
at least in the ground case so here is
your training data set
and your kernel will tell you how
similar each one is
okay that's the kernel and then
you take that similarity and you
aggregate
the labels of the training data points
since you know
and the labels they are in here so y
star
um it says ai here but
y i star so the true label is usually
what gives rise to this a it doesn't
need to be the true label but
in the simplest case you will simply
aggregate the labels of these data
points
in in proportion to how close they are
it's it's a bit of a nearest neighbor
classifier okay
so that's a kernel machine the important
thing is that there is this kernel
this is a function that tells you how
close any two data points are
and there is this sum right here so that
means that
your prediction y is going to be it can
be a func
nonlinear function of the sum but it's
going to contain a
sum over the training data
okay and each training data point
is measured in its similarity through
the kernel function and then the labels
of the training data points are
aggregated
that's a kernel machine so
you don't you don't need you know any
model for this right
the learned parameters here are often
the the a's and the
the b right here the offset however the
kernel can also be learned but
very often the kernel is also fixed and
you can see immediately that
choosing the kernel is the name of the
game in kernel machines and
before deep learning lots and lots of an
expert engineering has gone
into building kernels
to measure distances between data points
using kind of expert knowledge from a
field
it's probably still advisable today some
people claim we rely
too much on neural networks to do this
for us but
you know neural networks have been
pretty pretty good
so what's gradient descent you might
know gradient descent gradient descent
means that we do have a loss function
right here
and it is differentiable so what we can
do is we can simply
calculate the gradient with respect to
the loss function
and then change the parameters that
we're learning
into the direction of that gradient
and we arrive at a new at a new
weights and we repeat the process so
if you think of linear regression for
example you should simply have
x here and y here and you might have
sort of three data points like this
what would a kernel machine do a kernel
machine would do the following
if you're trying to classify a new data
point like this one right here
the kernel machine will go look which of
the data points that you already have
are close uh this one on the right here
is pretty close this one is kind of
close
this one is very far apart and then it
would sort of aggregate the labels and
it would say well since you
are very close i'm just kind of going to
copy your label
and maybe i'll adjust it a bit into the
direction of you who are also pretty
close a bit down so i might classify
myself as this
what would a linear regression
learn by gradient descent do on the
other hand you have the same data
points it would start out with a line
like like this any you know any any old
line will do randomly initialized and
then it would calculate
sorry it would calculate the gradient
and important in this paper we're always
talking about
full batch gradient so no stochastic
gradient descent which always means that
we always in every step consider the
entire data set
so here we ask this point and this point
says well maybe line you should you
should calm down a bit to the right
and then this data point also says well
maybe you should come a bit to the right
and this data point says well maybe you
should come a lot to the right
so that the line is going to shift to
the right
and ever so slightly it will arrive
at sort of this optimum right here
whereas the data point on the bottom
here says well i'm pretty fine
then this data point says you should
probably go up a bit and this one says
you'd probably go down a bit
so the line just stays at the same place
that's gradient descent
now we're going to connect the two and
in order to connect the two
we have to introduce these path kernels
right here these are
very connected to neural tangent kernels
which i'm an absolute noob at
but if you know that you already sort of
know
what's coming so we need this quantity
right here
which is the path kernel as we said in
kernel machines
choosing the kernel is the name of the
game and the goal of this paper is to
show
us that if you choose your kernel like
this
then a neural network or any model
learned by gradient descent
is a kernel machine with this particular
kernel okay so first of all
we need to understand what that kernel
is so what does a kernel do a kernel
measures
how close two different data points are
now you can measure this in in many ways
right
but here we need a very particular way
of measuring how close
two data points are so
what might be a bit special to you is
again consider a model that we learn
using gradient descent such as this
linear regression example we start out
with a line that's too steep
and we slowly come down right to the
line
that is the the optimum line so
what we've done is we've started with w0
and we slowly ended up with w and they
call it w
final right here okay so
during that time the weights took a path
if we draw the weights over time right
first
they were too high and then they came
down and now they are
still positive but they sort of converge
at this level
okay that here amounts to a path
so the the weights took a path during
learning the interesting thing in this
paper is
what we need to do is we need to
consider the entire path
from beginning to end so usually models
only store
you know the the converged optimum but
here
we assume right we assume we have a
model that's been trained
by gradient descent okay and that model
has a history
the history of gradient descent where we
start out at w0
and we go a path which is this curve you
see right here
2w final so imagine
that during radiant descent we have
stored
along the way we've stored every single
step of gradient descent now in this
paper we consider infinitely small steps
but just
imagine you know at every step we
actually stored the model
during training okay by the way this is
not a training procedure that we're
describing here
right we assume that we've already
trained the model
using radiant descent and now we have
the trained model and we want to see
how similar are two data points okay
so okay so let's say
we have a
we have a data point how do we classify
it for that you need to consider these
quantities right here
which is the gradient of the function of
y with respect to w so remember before
we said x to y
to the loss okay that's our thing
now usually usually
x to y is f our neural network
and that has parameters w so
usually what we do is we consider the
gradient of the loss function
with respect to the weights okay that's
what you usually do in gradient descent
so it connects it connects the weights
right here with the loss function right
here essentially it says
how do i need to change the weights to
make the loss change a certain way
okay now this quantity here is different
it only connects the weights it connects
the weights
to the w right here so
if you see this thing w of x this is the
same
as f of x right so y
is a function of x so this quantity
essentially says
if i change my weights how will
the the output of the neural network
change
not the loss how will the output change
that's kind of a sensitivity measure
okay so
imagine you have a neural network right
with
with a bunch of of weights a bunch of
layers
how and you have two data points x1 and
x2 these are training data points
and you have your new data point x now
you want to know is it similar to
x1 or x2 so what would you do in this
particular case what you do is you
forward propagate
both of these data points not to the
loss but to their
outputs okay so if
if your neural network let's consider
this as our linear regression example
and let's consider not
the not the beginning not the end but
let's consider a model
sort of this model right here okay and
you have two data points
x1 and x2
and we want to look at not the loss
right
we don't we want to look at if we use
the model
to output the data points as so
what's the gradient how how if we change
the weights either in this
or in this direction how does the output
change
now for this data point right here you
can see if we change the line a little
bit
the y value isn't going to shift as much
because we're very close to
the origin however for the data point up
here the
y value is going to shift more for a
given
amount of shifting the line so
the this is going to result in a number
right um x1 will have a gradient i don't
know
like three and x2
because gradient of so its gradient of
y with respect to w will be something
like nine
okay
and now the important part is we input
x so we input x and we also get a y from
the model
no we we never consider the labels here
so we have y
right here x right here we also use it
to predict
and now we ask if we now consider the
same thing
we now consider gradient of the output
of
this particular x with respect to the
weights what is it
and here you can see the point i've
drawn also is fairly
a lot away from the origin therefore
it's
it its output will shift a lot if the
weights shift
so maybe that's okay so now you can see
that by this number we can
now classify the similarity you can see
8 and 9 are much
closer than 3 and 8. okay
so two data points in this view are
similar
if if changing
the weights of the neural network
changes their outputs
in a similar way right so the outputs
here can actually
be vectors and so on uh if you want and
what you what you do is you consider the
inner product
between these gradients um
no sorry it's not that the output can be
vectors actually the weights are vectors
right
so you want to know how you need to
change the weight
to affect a particular change in the
in the output yes i was i formulated it
the wrong way
and in linear regression it ends up
being the same thing because you only
have one parameter
but usually you have uh
lots of parameters that means you get a
vector as this gradient and you consider
the inner product
of these vectors as your similarity
so what does it mean when two vectors
are
similar of these gradients it means that
if i for data point x
if i change my weights in a certain way
how will uh that affect why
or in other in other words if
i want my y to go up
what way do i need to change the weights
now it's correct
so for this data point if i want
the the y value to go up how do i need
to change my weights to achieve this
right
over here it's the same right if i want
my y to go up
um it's just the inverse like i need to
change the weights if i want to go to go
up by
one unit i need to change the weights by
1 9
and here by 1 8. i don't need to change
the weights much to make it go
wild because it's so far away from the
origin however
here i need to change my weights a lot
more like by one-third
in order to make the output move
all right so if
for two data points they need
similar changes to the weights in order
to affect the same change in output
they are considered similar okay they
they have a similar
effect on the neural network dynamics um
and here you can see this in action
so for a given weight configuration
we input all the three data points into
the neural network
we evaluate these gradients of the
output not of the loss of the output
with respect to the weights
and we compare that gradient of the
three data points it the new data point
will be closer to one of them than to
the other and that's how we evaluate
similarity now what does this path have
to do with this
so as i said here we've simply chosen
a model right we can we don't have to do
this for the final model we can do this
for any model
and in fact what we're going to do is if
we have a new data point
so remember that our model evolved from
this
down here to this if we have a new data
point
we're going to rewind time and
start out at the beginning with the
first model do this measurement like
compare our data point to all the other
data points
for this model then we're going to
advance
one step and we're going to do it again
and advance one step and we're going to
do it again
and we're going to consider the
similarity scores
over as an average over that path so
that means
in order to classify a data point in
this view as i said this is not a
practical algorithm
in order to classify a data point we're
going to retrace
the path of weights that the model took
during gradient descent when it was
learned we're going to
retrace that along the path
and for each step in the path we're
going to compare
our data points effect on the neural
network so the neural network's
sensitivity to our data point
and we're going to compare that with the
neural network's
sensitivity to all the data points in
our training
example and then
we're going to classify our data point
by whichever
data points in the training example had
a similar effect on the neural network
over the course of training okay so
we're not going to
train the network more or anything we're
simply going to replay
the path we took during radiant descent
and
by looking at how the data points affect
the network during that path in terms of
their gradients like
how much they pull on the network even
though we're not going to do the steps
by those poles we classify
how if two data points are similar or
not and that
is called this path kernel so we have
the most important quantity we have
already
if you made it through here good job
so here we have the tangent kernel
associated with function f so f is going
to be a neural network
w are weights x is a data point and
parameter vector v is going to be
the inner product of these two gradients
so two data points
are close in the tangent kernel if the
gradients
of those data points align so if the
inner product
is high okay and that's the tangent
kernel
and the path kernel now is simply the
tangent kernel
integrated over the path over any path
so this is not even gradient descent yet
we can do
any curve but the curve we're going to
end up looking is the curve that
gradient descent took
during training of the model so we're
going to look across the whole path
of gradient descent we're simply going
to integrate these tangent kernels
which gives us sort of an average and
average
tangent kernel over the course of
training
now theorem one is the main theorem it
says suppose
the model y equals
f w of x and
f is a differentiable function of w
that's a neural network
fulfills all of that is learned from a
training set
x i with y star i right so we have m
training data points by gradient descent
so we learn it by
full batch gradient descent so each and
every step we're going to consider the
whole
training data set we're going to
consider the loss with respect
as an average over the whole training
data set um
of x i so x i will give rise to
y i through the neural network and
that's going to be compared with
y i star and that's going to be our loss
we're going to differentiate the loss um
with a it says right here
with a differentiable loss function
which can be in regression
it can be the square loss right so the
loss function
is a sum here as you can see so this is
what the neural network predicts and
this is what you would like to have and
the loss function
simply compares the two and the learning
rate
epsilon then then
in the limit of infinitely small steps
and that's that's something you do in
order to be able to do
continuous analysis so it just think
if we if you take small enough steps
then
y equals this thing right here which is
exactly the form of a kernel
machine okay notice that
this and this are now connected
okay so that thing here um
this is f w of
x okay so the theorem essentially says
that the uh
the neural network can also be
represented
as a kernel machine where
k is the path kernel
associated with fw of x and the path
taken by the parameters during
radiant descent ai is the average
loss derivative along the path weighed
by the corresponding tangent kernel
and b is the initial model okay so
the important thing here is that this k
is going to be this path kernel we just
considered
and the path that we're looking at is
the path
taken by the parameters during gradient
descent we need all of those
things okay so we're going to the proof
and the proof as i said it's fairly
simple it's fairly straightforward
and it gives sort of an idea of um
how does connection come to be so first
of all we're going to consider
what does gradient descent do right if
we rewrite the equation of gradient
descent
we can see we can come to this so
this is one step of gradient descent um
and we're simply considering the
difference between two steps now the
difference is exactly going to be
the gradient because that's going to be
the steps and here is the step size
now as we let the step size go
to um infinitely small this of course
becomes a continuous
function so this is where the gradient
descent comes into play
we're saying that the way our weights
change over time
right this is the way our weights change
over time is always
in the direction of the negative
gradient of the loss function
right that's that's the continuous form
of gradient descent
now it says this is known as gradient
flow now we're going to consider a
different
quantity namely how do the neural
network
outputs change over time so
as we already said right um
no like we didn't already say this how
do the neural
network outputs change over time well i
can simply
um i can simply use the chain rule
here to expand this into the following
quantity so how do the neural network
outputs change over time
that's the derivative of the output with
respect to each of the weights
so this is this is over number of
parameters
um i'm going to
sum oh sorry over each of the parameters
and then how do these weights change
over time
okay so how the neural network output
changes over time
is defined by how the weights change
over time and
how the output reacts to those weight
changes
over time and it's a it's a sum with
with in accordance to the rules of total
differentiation
so now we've already seen the quantity
on the right
here right how do the weights change
over time
well they change according to the loss
gradient okay so we're simply going to
replace
this here by what we established before
so each weight changes according
to its derivative from sorry according
to the loss derivative with respect to
that weight
this is where gradient descent enters
the proof
now what we can do is we can apply the
additivity of the loss
so we know that the loss is always an
addition or a mean or a sum over the
training data
so now we're going to bring that in okay
so the loss here
this one we're going to split that up
into its components since the loss is a
sum
over the individual losses that means
the gradient of the loss or the
derivative
is also a sum of derivatives
and again the chain rule
we know that
x goes to by means of w goes to y
goes to l uh you can if you have
a gradient of l with respect to w you
can decompose that
as the gradient of l with respect to y
and then the gradient of y with respect
to w you young kids know this as back
propagation
um so that's exactly what we're going to
do right here
i'm going to split that up with the
chain rule
so now we have two quantities the first
quantity
is how does the loss change
with respect to the neural network's
output
right and that's pretty simple like this
is for linear regression
this is when where the loss is the
squared
norm difference or the squared then
this the norm of the difference of two
y's so the derivative is simply going to
be something like
the true label minus whatever the neural
network
outputs and the other quantity right
here
is how does the output of the neural
network
change with respect to the weights so if
i change the weights of the neural
network
right x if i change the weights a little
bit
how does the output change over here
this is a quantity
we've already seen i hope i hope so
right um okay meanwhile we've
we've pulled out the other quantity
right here
and you might recognize it as the same
quantity note that
this here this y i means that it's a
particular training data point
whereas this y is the actual point we
are trying to predict for a given
input okay so
now we simply rearrange a bunch of terms
and
look at that look at what comes out so
over here we rearrange this what you see
is uh sum over the number of parameters
again that's the number of parameters
and here why won't you see this here
is if i incorporate the sum
this is the gradient with respect to the
weights
of f of x and this here
is the gradient with respect to the
weights of f
of x i right because it's the if
training data point
and they are multiplied right the sum
and the product means that's
a dot product so this is exactly
this path this kernel the tangent kernel
okay this is the tangent kernel with
respect to a particular set
of weights w okay at a particular time
in the algorithm so at some point in
this path
that's um we choose a bunch of w's
and that's what results right this other
quantity right here as we said this is
the
relatively easy quantity that simply
defines
how a loss changes whenever the neural
network outputs change
and this is also now with respect to a
particular data point
so we're going to rewrite a bit right
here so this l prime
is going to be defined as that it's just
a bit of a rewrite
and here this is this tangent kernel
and now what we're going to do is we're
simply going to
aggregate all of this so since this
says how does y change over time during
the course
what we're going to do is simply we're
going to start off somewhere
go along the path and
we're going to aggregate all of the y
changes
during this so in this particular case
you know y goes up y goes up y
goes down y goes down if we aggregate
all of the changes in y
over the course of the of this path
we're going to end up with the final y
right so we're simply going to aggregate
all the changes in y
over this course which means we're if we
start out with a particular y
we're going to end up at the end so this
it's a bit special but this essentially
means that
if we look at the neural network
at the beginning of training right we
simply if we have a new data point
we're simply going to input it into the
w0 neural network
right and that gives us y0 that is
whatever the neural network would have
predicted
had we not trained it and then we're
going to
trace the changes in y this
the the d y d t we're going to trace
them
over the course of the training that
gradient descent has done
we're going to accumulate all of the
changes in y
that would have resulted had we input
our data point at each time
and what we're going to end up with is
the final y it's a very complicated
way of of because we could simply input
the data point
into the final model right uh that that
would be so much easier but we're going
to input it into the
start model then we're going to consider
how the output changes in each time step
and that's how we're going to end up at
the final y
so um yeah so as you can see now this is
already in the form of
kind of a kernel machine they're going
to make it a little bit more
uh like the classic form by actually
averaging
over this path kernel such that you end
up with this form
right here but essentially what you can
see is that
this thing here measures the distance
between data points
by means of retracing the steps along
radiant descent
and then this thing here is the
measures the loss derivative with
respect to these
data points now in order to actually
bring this into a kernel
form what um yeah as i said they they
normalize by this thing but it's
essentially the same
so i hope you can see that the
connection right here as i said you
always want to you have one way of
measuring distance
and then you want to aggregate the
values so you measure distance by how
sensitive
other data points are uh by how
sensitive other data points make the
network
and you see which of the other data
points makes the network
sensitive in a similar way to yours over
the course
of the gradient descent time
and once you have the similarities you
simply aggregate
their sort of opinion on the output
with respect with weighted by how
similar they affect the network
uh to your data point all right
that's how you come to conclude this
proof they have a lot of remarks right
here so they say
uh this for example this differs from a
typical kernel machines in that the ais
and b's depend on x which is something
that's not
you know the ai's and b's are usually
kind of learned but here they are
actually functions of x
which is a a difference um
to classic kernel machines so
essentially you can't
like in order to make this a kernel
machine right you
have to have the trained neural network
already so it's not like this is a new
training algorithm
um it simply casts these models
in the way of a kernel machine
and it's in my mind it's almost like a
it's a super general statement it it
also connects it to
uh to boosting um right here
i don't even know where but oh down here
in the discussion it connects it to
boosting
and it just seems like
at some point yeah you can just connect
all the learning algorithms to each
other
because all the learning algorithms um
will somehow incorporate the training
data into their weights like otherwise
they they wouldn't learn
and i feel like we're we're
rediscovering just different methods of
looking at problems now these different
methods the
you know a different way of looking at a
problem can give rise to
new and better algorithms because we
understand the problem
better but yeah it's it's in
some way it's not a surprise it's not a
surprise that neural networks
somehow store the training data because
of course any learning algorithm
must do so and that's exactly what this
this paper
shows and it shows what the exact kernel
is you have to choose
in order to make that claim um
solid so that was the paper i just want
to read the kind of
most at some point they say the most
important point
for this most significantly however
learning path kernels
machines via gradient descent largely
overcomes the scalability bottlenecks
that have long limited the applicability
of kernel methods to large data sets
uh computing and storing the gram matrix
at learning time with its quadratic cost
and the number of examples is no longer
required so
it makes a claim that if you want to
build a kernel machine
uh you might as well i don't actually
know what that means
does it mean you might as well find the
neural network that is equivalent to the
kernel
you want to build it i don't know if
that just
that just seems to turn out to um
to mean that you should build the neural
network that you like
but they kind of make the point that
neural networks don't discover new
representations new features what they
actually do is they discover
features uh that the
of of how you compare data points in
this gradient space
and they do that by means of of gradient
descent
and the paper it states that
this is you know this is very very
dependent
on how you choose the architecture so by
choosing the architecture of the neural
network
you sort of predispose the gradient
descent algorithm to find
certain certain features to compare data
points
as opposed to other features and the
paper again makes this explicit by
showing
how how this comparison comes about
namely by means of the gradients
with respect to the weights of the
output of the neural network
which of course is you know entirely a
function
of both the architecture and the loss
and the data set all right so i
hope you've enjoyed this let me know
what you think and i'll see you next
time bye